remember when pluto was a planet
until very recently pluto's planetary
status was an immutable fact led by
primary school kids the world over
pluto had an undisputed place in
papier-mache models of the solar system
and even its very own song lyric and
last of all there's pluto too
but in august 2006 pluto found itself
cruelly demoted to a dwarf planet after
failing to meet one of three criteria
the international astronomical union
uses to define
a full-size planet we are taught from an
early age to think of scientific facts
as well facts and it can be unsettling
when this turns out not to be the case
but does this uncertainty really mean
that we can't trust science
according to the royal society the
world's oldest independent
scientific academy the answer is quite
the opposite
questioning established facts is
actually at the heart of the scientific
method
think of the whole process as a giant
system of checks and balances
based on raw information drawn from
experiments or observations of nature
those experiments and observations lead
to the formulation of a hypothesis
which then goes through a rigorous
process of checks by other scientists
however there isn't always enough
information to draw the right
conclusions
take for example sir francis bacon who
noticed that the coastlines of west
africa
and eastern south america looked like
they were symmetrical
he believed that nature was copying
herself what he couldn't have known in
the early 1620s
is that the two coasts are two sides of
a fault line
in an ancient supercontinent which split
apart 140 million years ago
bacon's hypothesis remained gospel for
centuries
until new discoveries about the science
of plate tectonics emerged in the 1950s
and provided a neat explanation for
bacon's observation
there is also the fact that different
experts examining the same raw
data can draw different
spare conclusions thought for poor
robert plot who in the 1670s found a
fossilized bone that
he thought was that of a giant human
at least he wasn't around when a
geologist and zoologist proved it was in
fact a megalosaurus
a kind of dinosaur that roamed the earth
in the middle jurassic
sometimes the scientific method is all
about setting up groundbreaking
experiments
at the right time in the right place to
test theories
in 1919 a blockbuster meeting of the
royal society
confirmed einstein's theory of general
relativity
after a solar eclipse provided the
perfect circumstances
to measure the bending of starlight this
showed that the gravity of a massive
object such as the sun
could bend light around it under the
watchful eye of sir
isaac newton's portrait the scientific
community replaced newton's previous
theory
with einstein's newer and more general
interpretation of gravity
but even with evidence in its favor
einstein's theory still can't be thought
of as a fundamental fact
it's even possible that in the future
new breakthroughs will supersede our
understanding of general relativity
uncertainty in science isn't enough if
all the perspectives are the same
sometimes a lack of diversity in the
system can skew the results
until the 1970s primatologists were
mostly men
intended to limit their studies to male
primates
they believed that the aggression
observed in baboons meant
human evolution had been driven by
similar behavior
that was until anthropologist shirley
strum began observing both female and
male baboons
disproving these earlier theories and
facing a backlash for her troubles
scientists don't always get it right on
the first go but rather than instilling
doubt
it should inspire confidence that
outdated ideas are replaced when new
information becomes available
it's the difference between upgrading
your mobile and clinging to your old
rotary phone because you don't want to
be wrong
and in most cases newer breakthroughs
would not be possible without the
legwork that came before them
while a rotary phone isn't the best
available technology today
your smartphone wouldn't exist without
it
uncertainty is baked into the scientific
process
it's the fundamental reason that
progress is possible
ultimately it comes down to who you
trust more
the person who's certain they're right
or the person who's willing to be proved
wrong
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification
each time we upload a new video